après quatre ans d'attentes 2000
militaires américains en mission en
afghanistan et 500 en irak vont rentrer
chez eux
date limite de départ le 15 janvier
prochain
seulement cinq jours avant l'investiture
du prochain président des états unis
une promesse de donald trump tenue in
extremis mais tous ne prendront pas le
chemin du retour
environ 2500 militaires américains
resteront dans chacun des deux pays
près de vingt ans après l'arrivée des
premiers contingents envoyés par
washington sur place la population
s'inquiète allemande banamba ep talibans
vont intensifier la violence dans le but
de s'emparer d'un plus grand pouvoir
politique en afghanistan mais dans ce
pays sur une voie dangereuse que le
retrait des troupes étrangères
d'afghanistan entraînera une escalade de
la violence des talibans dans tout le
pays et il fera également soit frères
davantage les familles les rendra
incapable à taissy elles quittent
l'afghanistan la sécurité pourrait être
encore plus menacée et la nuit pourrait
atteindre davantage de ses objectifs pas
d'inquiétude pour le porte parole du
conseil national de sécurité afghan
selon lui la quasi-totalité des
opérations militaires sont déjà
conduites par les forces afghanes
de leurs côtés les talibans se dit
satisfait selon leurs représentants
cette décision permettrait de mettre fin
à la guerre plus rapidement mais cette
annonce inquiète certains pays notamment
l'allemagne
nous sommes particulièrement préoccupés
parce que l'annoncent des états unis
pourrait signifier pour la poursuite des
pourparlers de paix en afghanistan sans
nécessité nous ne devrions pas créer
d'obstacles supplémentaires ce à quoi un
retrait hâtif de l'afghanistan conduire
est très certainement
autre crainte la résurgence des groupes
terroristes
les attentats du 11 septembre 2001 ont
été orchestrées par le groupe jihadiste
al qaïda à l'époque ils étaient basés en
afghanistan où l'avait accueilli les
talibans vingt ans de guerre s'en sont
suivis dans le pays selon le pentagone
en afghanistan et en irak
près de 7000 militaires américains sont
morts
plus de 52000 ont été blessés depuis les
premières offensives militaires
américaines